Speaker 1: Donald Trump held his second 2020
to rally.
These rallies now are very clearly 2022 focused
other than still being focused on the 2020
election, which Donald Trump continues to
claim falsely that he won.
But the rallies are getting far more dangerous,
far more insidious and corrosive.
They're now actually starting to sort of tease
the idea of more riots in the future.
If Trump doesn't get what he wants, Trump
also dangling pardons for the Jan. six, 2021,
rioters at this rally.
And the dangerous part is, I don't want to
say it's not.
The dangerous part is partially that the rally
exists and the things that Donald Trump says,
but it's hugely that there's a crowd of people
who go there, thousands of people who want
to hear this stuff.
Now we had two people on the ground at the
rally.
They filmed some very disturbing interviews,
including one individual who admitted that
he was in the Capitol on January six.
And we, of course, will be turning that over
to law enforcement will have those videos
for you tomorrow.
We had Luke Beasley and Josh Pitt on the ground
for today.
We're going to look at what the rally actually
consisted of.
Now, of course, the framing of the rally is
always a lie.
In this case, it was that there were 85000
people at the rally.
There were not eighty five thousand people.
There were thousands, though.
And that already should concern all of us.
And in particular, some of the claims Donald
Trump made are particularly authoritarian
and fascistic.
You know, a principle of authoritarians is
they don't respect the law.
They use the law as a tool when they can use
it for their personal gain.
But when the law is an obstacle to their personal
gain, they say they will go around the law
and that's exactly what Donald Trump did.
Now, before we even get to that, Trump really
struggling through this one, the teleprompter
reading losing his place, getting confused.
Just a couple examples to set the stage for.
You know, again, in this case, Trump's right
eye swollen, almost completely shut.
And he looked confused by what was on the
prompter.
Here's just one example.
Speaker 3: They censor, cancel and persecute
ordinary citizens for speaking the truth while
they drown your endless torment of, I mean,
what they do.
They have an endless.
List of propaganda and propaganda methods,
Speaker 1: so a lot of that during the entire
rally here is Trump referring to the country
of Maxell Co. the
Speaker 3: biggest beneficiaries.
It's such a good deal that Mexico and Canada,
you saw that Mexico and Canada want to get
out of it.
Speaker 1: And then lastly, Donald Trump also
looking extremely confused talking about the
sinister faces of corruption lawless.
Speaker 3: This is a tragedy, but they are
sinister faces of corruption.
Lawless?
Speaker 1: Yeah, just losing his place frequently.
But let's get to the substance.
May be the craziest part of this is that Donald
Trump says if he is reelected, he may pardon
people.
And he is threatening unrest.
Let's start there.
Trump actually threatening more riots.
Speaker 3: If these radical, vicious, racist
prosecutors do anything wrong or illegal,
I hope we are going to have in this country
the biggest protest we have ever had in Washington,
DC, in New York, in Atlanta and elsewhere
because our country and our elections are
corrupt.
Speaker 1: So he's saying there, if the prosecution
of the Trump rioters continues in a way I
will say is unfair, which he's already doing.
Then we need to do more of these so-called
biggest protests.
And at this point, everybody knows what that
means.
Everybody understands that he's not talking
about peaceful protests, he's talking about
more riots and maybe even more perniciously
perniciously.
Trump says if he's reelected, he's going to
look at pardons for the people who did the
rioting.
Speaker 3: How many people have been asking
me about it?
If I run and if I win, we will treat those
people from January six fairly.
We will treat them fairly.
And if it requires pardons, we will give them
pardons because they are being treated so
unfairly.
Speaker 1: Now that is not due process and
the rule of law that is politically these
people are on my side.
So we're going to come in and give them pardons,
even though I don't really know anything about
their individual cases and that the the important
thing here is consider how jarring this is
in comparison to the original story that it
wasn't even really Trumpists that were there,
it was Antifa and Black Lives Matter.
The first story was it wasn't Trumpists, it
was Antifa dressed as Trumpists.
It was Black Lives Matter dressed as Trump.
There were some peaceful Trump supporters,
maybe, but they certainly didn't do anything
wrong.
Then they shifted into.
It was a false flag done by the FBI raps,
and it was Tucker.
Push this story.
Then for a little while, it was, I guess,
the FBI and Antifa.
Now it was Trumpists.
All of a sudden, I guess.
But Trump will pardon them because they're
not getting a fair shake.
They're not being treated fairly.
So I guess it was an antifa.
Or more realistically, it no longer matters
to the story, because now the new one is elect
me and I will pardon these people.
Now, many of you probably would think if I
told you, Trump bragged about his dementia
test again, you'd say.
But yeah, but David, it's almost February
of 2022.
Didn't he take that test like in the middle
of 2020?
He's not what you would be, right?
He's still bragging about the dementia test.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: You know, they were getting a little
nasty.
They didn't like that.
We were doing so well.
So they said, maybe this guy's not with it.
And I said, Ronnie, can I take some kind of
a test?
Is there something like, Are you cancer?
But it's very hard now.
Speaker 1: The number of times Trump says
sir during a story is directly proportional
to how it's inversely proportional to the
truth of the story.
So the more he says, sir, the more untrue
the story is.
We figure that out, and there is a lot of
sirs here.
Speaker 3: I said, What's hard?
Well, the first questions are easy.
But then it gets harder and harder when you
get to question number three.
It's pretty hard, sir.
I said, Well, would anyone know if I did badly,
right?
He said, Well, you know it is Walter Reed.
A lot of people see what's happening.
I'd better do well, even.
Speaker 1: That's interesting because basically
what Trump saying is, why don't I take it?
And if I don't do well, we just don't release
it?
Speaker 3: He said, What do you think?
I said, I don't know.
I did pretty well in my life.
Let's take it, and I took this cognitive test.
Speaker 1: Now it's really again, it's important,
Trump says I did well in my life.
So let's do a cognitive test, the test, it's
the Montreal cognitive assessment.
It's just meant to screen for serious dementia.
Whether you did well in school or not doesn't
actually have a bearing on whether you are
now suffering from a medical condition.
He still doesn't get it.
Speaker 3: And as Ronnie said, I got every
single question, right?
He said, I him.
And you know, from that point on, they didn't
talk.
They found other things.
Then they said he wants to be a dictator who
wants to be.
They went on to other things, but I think
Biden should do the same thing running.
Would you administer the test, please?
It would solve so many problems.
I have a feeling he won't be doing it anytime
soon, do you agree?
But seriously, Ronny Jackson, so
Speaker 1: there it's still a topic, a president,
a former president bragging about how he passed
the dementia test.
Then Donald Trump complained that prosecutors
are out there to get Trump unfairly.
This causes the crowd to chant, Lock her up
about Hillary.
But how jarring is it that Trump saying there's
prosecutorial misconduct against me?
And meanwhile, the crowd is chanting to lock
up Hillary, who hasn't even been charged with
a crime.
I thought he was about due process, I guess
not
Speaker 3: local prosecutors in New York and
other locations who horribly campaigned for
office on.
We're going to get Trump.
This is how they campaign.
They know nothing about me.
We are going to get him.
Then got elected and are working overtime
to fulfill their Cain campaign promises.
They've subpoenaed more than.
Speaker 1: It's it's really something, I mean,
he says these prosecutors aren't behaving
correctly, we have we.
Everything needs to be done the right way.
Yet lock up Hillary, who's not even been been
accused.
Never mind charged of any crime.
Trump doing his supply chain stuff, of course.
Speaker 3: Can you believe what's happened?
You can't get anything.
The shelves are empty.
I did a book.
They can't publish it anymore.
They can't get the paper, the glue, the ink,
go out and buy it.
You'll like it.
Speaker 1: Every opportunity to promote his
book is an opportunity Trump takes.
And then lastly, may be the one bit of truth
from the rally.
Trump says when Republicans retake Congress,
they will investigate the Biden family that
he's probably telling the truth about.
I do believe they will do that,
Speaker 3: and Biden has the real scandals.
Then rest assured, when Republicans retake
Congress to Biden, corruption will be investigated
and exposed by Congress.
But we no longer have the Free and fair press,
if we did, all of this would end it.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I think that's that's the
one piece I think he's telling the truth about.
As I've said before, I believe if Republicans
win in November, they will investigate Biden.
They will investigate Biden's family.
They may even impeach Joe Biden, won't convict
in the Senate, but they may even impeach Joe
Biden.
So an extraordinarily corrosive rally and
these are going to continue.
He is going to play a role in 2020 to later
in the show.
I'll tell you about or tomorrow.
Rather, new polling is not so good for Trump
among the Republican Party, but it's certainly
not stopping
the rallies.